[Música]
la mayoría de los libros le dirán que el
Imperio Romano cayó en el siglo V
después de Cristo Pero esto hubiera sido
una gran sorpresa para millones de
personas que vivieron en el Imperio
Romano durante la Edad Media este
Imperio Romano medieval al cual nos
referimos hasta hoy como el Imperio
bizantino comenzó en el 330 después de
Cristo fue cuando Constantino el primer
emperador cristiano mudó la capital del
Imperio Romano a una nueva ciudad
llamada Constantinopla fundada en la
antigua ciudad griega de
bizancio cuando los visigodos saquearon
Roma en el 410 después de Cristo y las
provincias occidentales del imperio
Fueron conquistadas por los bárbaros la
capital oriental de Constantino se
transformó en la sede de los emperadores
que gobernaron allí Durante los
siguientes 11 siglos al convenir la
continuidad del Imperio Romano clásico
dieron al imperio bizantino ventajas
tecnológicas y artísticas sobre sus
vecinos a quienes los bizantinos
consideraban bárbaros en el siglo noveno
visitantes de Más allá de la frontera
quedaban asombrados con los elegantes
Arcos y cúpulas del palacio Imperial en
Constantinopla un par de leones dorados
flanqueaban el trono Imperial un órgano
escondido hacía a los leones rugir
mientras los invitados caían de rodillas
pájaros dados cantaban en un árbol de
oro cercano ingenieros romanos
medievales incluso usaban motores
hidráulicos para Elevar el trono
Imperial en el aire otros aspectos
heredados de la antigua cultura romana
se podían ver en la ropa del emperador
desde su vestimenta tradicional hasta
las togas y en los tribunales donde
seguían usando la ley romana la clase
trabajadora bizantina tenía vidas
similares a sus contrapartes de la
antigua Roma muchos practicaron o
tuvieron oficios comerciales como
cerámica peletería pesca tejidos y
manufactura de seda Pero por supuesto el
Imperio bizantino no solo descansó sobre
Los laureles de la antigua Roma los
artistas innovaron crearon mosaicos y
tallas de mármol ornamentadas sus
arquitectos construyeron numerosas
Iglesias una de las cuales Santa Sofía
tenía una cúpula tan alta que se decía
que colgaba de una cadena desde el
cielo el Imperio fue cuna de Grandes
intelectuales como an ni como princesa
Imperial en el siglo xii Ana dedicó su
vida a la filosofía y la historia su
relato del reinado de su padre es la
principal fuente histórica de la
historia política bizantina en los
tiempos de la primera Cruzada otro
erudito Leo el matemático inventó un
sistema de balizas a lo ancho del
imperio en los actuales Grecia y Turquía
con más de 700 km de extensión este
sistema permitía avisarle al emperador
de Invasores en la frontera del imperio
en una hora desde su avistamiento en la
frontera pero sus avances no pudieron
proteger al imperio Eternamente en 1203
un ejército de cruzados franceses y
venecianos hicieron un trato con un
hombre llamado alexios angelos alexios
era el hijo de un emperador depuesto y
les prometió a los cruzados grandes
riquezas y apoyo si lo ayudaban a
recuperar el trono en manos de su tío
alexios tuvo éxito pero después de un
año la población se reveló y alexios fue
depuesto y asesinado Así que el ejército
sin paga volvió su agresión contra
Constantinopla generaron incendios que
destruyeron incontables obras literarias
y de arte antiguas y medievales y
dejaron sin hogar a un tercio de la
población la ciudad fue recuperada 50
años después por el emperador Romano
Miguel paleólogo pero su imperio nunca
recuperó todo el territorio que los
cruzados habían conquistado en
145 tres el emperador otomano mehmed el
conquistador tomó Constantinopla y dio
fin definitivamente al imperio romano a
pesar de la conquista otomana muchos
grecar lantes del Mediterráneo Oriental
continuaron considerándose romanos hasta
principios del siglo XXI De hecho no fue
Sino hasta el renacimiento que el
término imperio bizantino se usó por
primera vez para los europeos
occidentales el renacimiento era
reconectar con la sabiduría de la antig
y como la existencia de un imperio
romano medieval sugería que algunos
europeos nunca habían perdido contacto
con la antigüedad los occidentales
querían trazar una línea Clara entre
épocas para distinguir mejor el clásico
Imperio Romano pagano latino parlante
del Imperio Romano medieval cristiano y
Greco parlante los académicos
denominaron a este último como bizantino
y así 100 años después de haber caído
nació el Imperio
bizantino obtenga sobre los vecinos del
imperio bizantino los mongoles que bajo
el liderazgo de jis kh se convirtieron
en el Imperio terrestre colindante más
grande de la historia descubra más con
este video